have you been allegedly the last project
we got here the fans just predicted
she's back
after her last performance at the 2018
Grammys Rihanna is set to make her
return at the Apple music Super Bowl 57
halftime show taking place this Sunday
in Glendale Arizona we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
nine-time Grammy winners performance
before she shines bright like a diamond
on the world's biggest stage and right
now
the Barbados Beauty will follow last
year's All-Star lineup which included
headliner Dr Dre with appearances by
Mary J Blige Snoop Dogg 50 Cent Eminem
and Kendrick Lamar speaking with
Entertainment Tonight she says this was
a Now or Never opportunity after
welcoming a baby boy with ASAP Rocky
last May explaining you could get real
comfortable being at home as a mom so
this is challenging myself to do
something that I've never done before in
my career I have to live up to that
challenge and while Riri hasn't released
a new album since 2016 we're certain her
setlist will live up to the hype with
the 34 year old predicted to perform
some of her biggest hits
[Music]
the Fenty Beauty MoGo will be working
closely on the show with Jay-Z who
originally signed the star back in 2005
and is served as the NFL's live music
entertainment strategist since 2019.
Rihanna tells E.T she hopes to bring a
lot of culture saying I want to
incorporate different aspects of
entertainment and things that I just
enjoy and bring it to the stage I want
to celebrate the music that I've made as
for special guests well it's yet to be
confirmed if there will be appearances
by other artists or if Rihanna will be
performing solo TMZ reports the singer
and her team have been working with a
list of 50 possible names with sources
claiming that guests could include
artists that Rihanna has collaborated
with in the past like Pharrell Calvin
Harris and Drake
[Music]
one guess we can expect however is
Rihanna's adorable nine-month-old son
oh
a source tells Hollywood Life she knows
it's going to be loud so she's thinking
that either she'll have him wear noise
canceling headphones for babies or her
family many of which are also coming
we'll enjoy the show from a Skybox or
some type of Club seating of course her
partner ASAP Rocky will also be
attending recently sharing his
excitement with Zane Lowe on Apple music
one oh I'm super excited
huge this is this is incredible I'm so
glad that my lady's back making music
again and whatnot and and getting back
out there you know it's just incredible